il ya des milliers de personnes sur ces
plateformes ils ont le droit de savoir
ce qui se passe
il faut prévenir ces gens
[Musique]
non
revient
on parle d'un glissement de quelle
ampleur disons pour faire court qu'il
n'y en a pas eu de tel depuis des
millénaires
dans une zone remplie de plateformes et
de genre oui
pour ma combien de temps
rohmer dont
ils vont emménager chez moi c'est vrai
mais nouveau départ ne votez pas
quel est le pire scénario envisageable
toute la côte ouest de la norvège sera
complètement dévastées du nord au sud
toute la faune et la flore il faudra des
dizaines d'années pour réparer les
dégâts voire un siècle
ce petit garçon va perdre son papa à
cause de vous
il y arriver un truc à papa
je vous confie au dîner
sofia est là bas
nous sommes face à un défi colossal
on n'a jamais rien connu de ce genre
personnes a été entraîné à ça
[Musique]
sofia